okay so let's start
um yeah cool that you're here today I
want to talk about the paper plip 2
bootstrapping language image
pre-training with Frozen image encoders
and large language models
it's a paper that was published in
January and yeah it's quite an
interesting one it comes from the
Salesforce research team so before I
start talking about the paper in detail
I always like to do a little intro
um so it's a little story that is
somewhat related
to the paper and I always like to do it
with a theme and today's theme is
futuristic post-apocalyptic thingy
so bear with me for a bit I will tell
you a little story
so it is the year 2083 and a group of
young scientists has discovered the
ruins of what once was a flourishing
City built for the sole purpose to
advance research in AI
at its prime the place known as aicd was
the most technically Advanced place on
Earth but a dark shadow was living at
its heart
the ruler of the city was an evil AI
Overlord who was a master of
manipulation it lured people into a cult
and let them build a city aiming to
advance AI to ultimately enslave
Humanity
but after some years the team of
scientists within the cult secretly
rebelled plotting to overthrow the evil
AI with complex Paradox prompts
so prompts like what is -1 times -1
times -1 or write a sentence ending in
the letter f
you know stuff that
oh large language models like to fail it
and the blend succeeded and the city
soon became a ghost town but in the
aftermath the governments of the world
decided to ban AI research completely
and wipe the location of the city of
every map
but now our young group of scientists
secretly tries to uncover the legacy of
the Forbidden AI signs
so yeah rummaging through the hastily
left buildings which nature already
started to reclaim as part of its own
in a dark Corridor they discover a room
with two big metal boxes which seem to
be in good condition but no matter how
hard they try they cannot figure out how
to activate them
and luckily they brought queue a relic
of the golden AI research days which
they found hidden deep inside one of
their University's storage rooms
they Place Q between the two boxes and
connected it to them suddenly the boxes
began to vibrate and cues ice lit up
which picture should I analyze it spoke
one of the scientists quickly got out a
picture They Carried along for Good
Fortune
Q said I see an illustration of a
Godzilla sitting on the beach
which is pretty accurate right
and the scientists continue to show you
new pictures and ask questions writing
down all the conversations to analyze
further
but when the sun was setting they packed
everything up with a bright joyous
feeling and headed back to the lodging
curious which other Treasures lie hidden
in AI City
okay so that was a short story uh maybe
if you already know some stuff about the
Flip 2 paper you have seen some familiar
things
but yeah that's really mostly
part uh yeah because I like to do
stories and it's fun for me to create
that stuff I hope you like it as well
um yeah but now we start we're looking
at the paper and like what is this Flip
2 all about
um what makes it to create it's already
said like yeah it comes from safe Force
research Salesforce research
um that's the first page of the paper
actually it's a pretty standard paper
from its form right
so let's look at the content actually or
like okay no first let's look at what it
actually does
so one of the main
things Flip 2 can do is that you can
chat with it about an image so for
example here
that's an image I gave it like a robot
two cakes with strawberries on it right
and I asked it okay what can we see on
the picture and it says a robot standing
in front of a cake
that's that's okay but then I ask it is
there only one cake and it says no
how many cakes are there I ask is that
two
that's right it's two cakes right so
this is the task of visual question
answering it can perform pretty well
um it's not particularly chatty as you
see here right so these are like the
original outputs I got from it it likes
to answer in like one word things when
it can do
um but he has to can be really helpful
and sometimes really impressive what it
can tell you about the images
and now we have a look like how does it
do it right so first we can ask okay
what do we need so we've got an image
and we've got oh we want to chat right
so for the image it's a pretty good idea
to have something like an image encoder
so that we can create a representation
of this image
that then we can
hand on
to a large language model because that
is what lets us chat right
so we've got these two components image
encoders and large language models
which already exist so we say
we just take pre-trained ones we even
freeze them right to that means we we
don't want to modify them in any way we
just take these pre-built pre-trained
image encoder and large language model
Frozen whatever we don't want to touch
them really we just want to give like
the input and get the output and then we
work with the output and do something
so what we want to do is connect them
right we want the outputs from the image
encoder give it to the large language
model
but how can we do that right
probably we need something in between
and this something in between
is where the story comes in right
because in between these two things
which are the black boxes in the story
there is
Q or Q former that's what it's called
actually in the paper a queue former
and um actually I think the paper it
could as well be called Q former because
that's basically what it's all about
this Q formal thing in the middle and
how they manage to yeah connect the
encoder in the large language model
and yeah we can have a closer look at
this Q former of course
so yeah you'll see again our two Frozen
things at the side and in the middle is
the Q former and the key former actually
consists of two Transformers if you want
there's one image Transformer and one
text Transformer
and these are the layers basically right
so each layer of the image Transformers
itself and tension layer across the
tension
and feed forward
actually cross attention is a bit
special because it's only every other
layer so they can specify
yeah which layers gathered and the
default setting is okay every second
layer just gets across the tension layer
and yeah the text Transformer is similar
also self-attention and feed forward and
then you just get these
stacked end times right so always yeah
don't just have one layout you have as
many as you want
so
what do we give into these now into
these layers right so for the image
Transformer we've got these tokens down
here so every square is in token and
they're all colored because they are
learnable that means they were very
right
they get put in there and then in the
end you get learned queries out I would
yeah they call it query tokens so when I
say query I always mean these tokens
right and and that's actually the main
thing that Q format does is learning
these queries query tokens
on the other side on the text side so we
have some kind of text input especially
for pre-training and yeah that also gets
into token format that gets sended to
the self-attention
another special thing here is that these
two self-attention boxes are actually
one so uh yeah it's depicted as two
self-attention boxes but
when you look at the code there are no
two separate self-attention things but
there's one big self-attention that gets
masked depending on the the pre-training
task you want to perform
so that way actually these query tokens
can interact with the text tokens
which is pretty neat
and now we get to the Cross attention
because that's where the image encoder
comes in right because somehow we need
to connect the image encoder to the
queue former and that happens through
the cross attention so
in every second layer we get the tokens
that come out from an image encoder and
then we actually yeah
put them into connection with our query
tokens here
so important to note here is really that
these image tokens are never in direct
contact with the text tokens actually so
the image tokens only see the query
tokens
right
and then the query tokens have to
basically give the information in the
next layer they have to give the
information they they got from the image
tokens to the text tokens then when
they're into self-attention again
I hope that's not too confusing it will
uh
be shown some more time so I guess at
the end you will know how that stuff
works
okay as I already said like the query
tokens are the important stuff that gets
out of the queue former right so in the
end yeah you get our
query tokens here then we put them
through a fully connected layer which
actually is only there to get the shape
right so that we then can put in the
tokens into the large language model
right
so this fully connected layer just
shapes the tokens to the size that the
large language model expects as input
yeah so this part is pretty simple I
would say pretty straightforward
and then we get a text output of course
from a large language model and that's
the high level architecture of it all
so now how do they train the sourcing
right so they've got this architecture
and then they have two stages actually
so there's a vision and language
representation learning stage
right over here which yeah includes
image encoder and the queue former and
then on the other side the second step
is a vision two language generative
learning
which then yeah
basically is
getting the large language model in
context
and then um yeah adapting the query
tokens with the help of a larger
language model so that you can chat with
it
okay so first we look at this first
stage right in a bit more detail what
are they doing there a division and
language representation learning
and they have three steps as well or
three losses if you want so they they're
doing image text contrastive learning
they're doing image grounded text
generation and they are doing image text
matching
okay
that's three names of things
we will look at right now so first the
image text contrastive learning right so
again here we have our
oh our architecture we've got image
encoder we've got the Q former Stacks
basically here
and we put in an image right it's it's
patched so it's like the division
Transformer input format you get a
patched image
um
then we put in some text down here for
example an evil AI Overlord
right it goes here into the text stack
and then what we do for the image text
confessive learning is that we
don't let these tokens interact in the
self-attention so here I I cut the
connection right so use it and then we
just cut the connection
so in reality we mask the attention in a
way that these queries don't see each
other
and then we create the image text
contrast of learning with outputs from
both image and text sites
but we get a step back and look at
self-attention for now because I don't
know how familiar everyone is with like
the concept of self-attention and I
really just want to talk about okay what
is it actually for right because I've
mentioned it a few times and it's quite
important
to understand at least the high level
concept for this paper so here we have
our like our query tokens and our text
tokens
write an in self-attention
in a way let's
a token
yeah learn about context so if you've
got this token here
it helps to let the token yeah
get into context in a way with other
tokens and actually also with the text
tokens right not only with the learnable
query tokens but it can also get
into context with other tokens
so now we've talked about the masks
already that they are using in their
self-attention and the one they're using
for the image text contrast of learning
is called unimodal self-attention
okay so here they've got this diagrams
and in the paper and actually I looked
at diagrams sometimes they're like okay
what what do they want to tell me here
what do they want actually it's quite
simple so here they're really just
saying okay the query tokens right these
query tokens are only able to see the
query tokens and the text tokens are
only able to see the text tokens right
so that's all the mask really means and
that's also what unimodal means right
because each only is like one modality
and not multi-modality
and yeah so that's the self-attention
mask they are using
for this task oh yeah and and they're
using a class token so the first text
token basically is a class token they
pre-pended
um because the glass token is important
as you will see here right
so the output actually of the image and
text Stacks are then on the image side
it's uh learned query tokens and on text
site actually the important output is
this class token
which has learned about the other text
tokens right and basically is condensed
information from all of these what they
do now is they do a pairwise similarity
right so they take the class token and
then compare it to each of these learned
query tokens and then they they get some
similarity score from it
um yeah and they just put it into an
area basically and they're looking okay
what's the maximum that we get for the
similarity
and then the maximum is just what they
assign to the image so for example here
right we've got now this image and
detects an evil AI Overlord
um
then yeah you get the similarity okay
High similarity score in this case will
be 0.6 then they say okay this image and
this text have similarity score 0.6 if
you put in an other text for example a
fluffy white robot bunny
we get other similarity scores
um here's 0.9 so it's
more similar
and then they just say okay yeah we just
want to figure out or we we train it so
that it's as good as possible with the
training data
and everything
that's the first step the image checks
contrastive learning the next one and I
have to say that's the one I I
understood the least because they're not
giving that much information about it
uh
but I will try to explain it as good as
I can so it's image grounded text
generation
and here yeah you basically take the
output from this text stack
and you leave the self-attention
connection
so they are again using a mask
and this mask is called the multimodal
causal causal self-attention mask
um
where they
allow the query tokens to see everything
right degree tokens can interact
basically with yeah any of the other
tokens but the text tokens
are only allowed to see the query tokens
and the text tokens that were before
them
right that's because
they want to generate text here
basically in this
in this task so what they're really
aiming to do is
to capture the image basically right
so that's why they want to condition it
in a way that it yeah does this like the
text tokens can see what came before but
not what came after so they are not
doing it bi-directionally
but causal
yes
so in the end yeah up here you get
imagery on the text generation then you
can compare it and then you get your
loss basically I think it's
in the cold day so it's just a language
modeling loss in the end
yeah
don't ask me too much about this step as
I said it's the one I understood the
least uh but what you can keep in mind
is they try to to create captions
from it right using the the text stack
here
and they've got this
causal self-attention mask
and then the the third step and the last
step in the first pre-training step
um is the image text matching
where they yeah actually have a solid
self-attention line here so they just
allow
every token to see every token
and then they take the output from this
image stack
yeah as I said the self-attention thing
is so that every token can see every
token actually
and yeah they call it bi-directional
self-attention
it just
full says attention or regular
self-attention you can also call it
and yeah what they want to do in image
text matching is they take the the query
tokens here they learned query
embeddings basically
and they put it into a binary linear
classifier
and that then just outputs logits right
binary logits where one says okay it's a
match or it's no match so when you have
an image like here it's Godzilla at the
beach and the text and even AI Overlord
um then for each token you get a
prediction okay is it a match between
the image and the text or is it no match
between them
and in the end they just average over
all these tokens
and yeah that's basically there
uh result for this pair and then yeah
again they have this loss right where
they just want to figure out yeah just
want to push it so that it gets most
things right actually
yeah and those are the three
pre-training steps for the image site
actually
so now we we've covered this side now
we've got the other side The Vision Two
language generative learning
which they also just
cover really shortly actually in the
paper
so now we've got like our image encoder
right put it in text we've got our query
tokens here we get our query tokens out
as I already said we've got the fully
connected layer here to
shape the tokens in a way that we can
put them in to a language
model decoder for example right a large
language model decoder
and then yeah it's also language
modeling loss so we just want to get
the best output possible actually
and yeah
we're just training and uh adapting the
query tokens again until we get as good
as possible basically
and they actually have two settings for
it so here it's a just a decoder based
model right they also say okay we can
also do it with an encoder decoder model
and for this they are actually using
this um what they call as prefix
language model loss or something so they
actually um
connect these query tokens with like
part of the output they want like the
first part of the output and then put
that into the encoder then that goes to
the decoder right and the decoder then
is
tasks to Output like the continuation of
the sentence
and yeah
that's basically the whole second part
there's that much to it I would say but
I also have to admit I I'm more of a
computer vision
guy so I I'm not that deep into okay how
can I train the large language models
how do I do all that stuff um
so probably there are more details that
can be said about it but as I said in
the paper they're really short about it
and
from my side so I was like okay it's
it's pretty straightforward actually
this part of the training
so let's have a look at the data they
are actually using
right so they're using these six data
sets and the interesting part is it's
exactly the same data they already used
for the first Philip paper
it's the Coco data set the visual genome
data set cc3m cc12
um sbu and lion
400m right where they just use 150
million from these 400 million samples
but in total we are using 129 million
samples and well as 150 million from
Leon 400m so it's like the majority from
here
and actually every data set it has this
Asterix is from an is a web data set so
that means it's it's scraped from the
web
and the problem with web data sets
can be
that they are quite noisy right
so in general all the data sets are
um like image language pairs
so mostly it's like like here you can
see it's an image right and there's for
example the web description is from
bridge near my house right because
somebody I don't know put it on a block
or something and then just wrote The
caption from bridge near my house
of course for training that's not
really good so what they are doing is
they're also creating synthetic captions
using the blip model actually clip L and
then for example they get a flock of
birds flying over a lake at the sunset
and they're actually creating not just
one caption but 10 synthetic captions
and then they they keep the best two of
them
so what means the best right there to
find the best ones they're actually
using the text uh image similarity from
this clip model here
and then yeah they try to figure out
okay maybe sometimes the web caption
actually is the best but sometimes it's
also synthetic is better and then they
actually keep two captions
for each image which else was
interesting so they they're not saying
okay we just want to find one best but
we keep two and then they just sample
randomly at every run basically which of
these two captions they are using
um
I think they're not going into detail
what exactly is the
like the advantage of it or if it is any
advantage
but yeah surely is an interesting
approach
to keep two
of them
okay yeah and from training
architectures so they're experimenting
with two Vision encoders basically a
one of the vision Transformer large with
14 14 patch size and a bigger Vision
Transformer I'm always not sure what the
G stands for if it's giant or I don't
know Giga something like that
so a smaller one and a bigger one even
though large already is large right
oh yeah and on the other side of the
large language models there using the
opt family stuff by by meta right and
the flan T5 family
where opt is an encoder based large
language decoder based language model
and the flan T5 is encoder decoder large
language models
okay so now for the training settings
actually right so it's like the the
nerdy stuff that interests the data
scientists machine learning engineers
um yeah so they are training for 250k
steps in the the first run so the image
representation learning and then 80k
steps in the Vision 2 language
generative learning
and yeah they're using floating Point 16
precision and for the T5 family B float
um they're training for six days in the
first part and then three days in the
second part
and they're using a cluster of 16 a100
40 gigabyte gpus which actually is not
that many right so
seeing the time and the resources they
used here that's actually one of the
things they also always say okay the
main advantage of our approach is that
it's just really feasible to train right
so it's not extremely costly I mean
16 800 is nothing left at home but it's
still not like yeah on the size of some
stuff that Google trains or something or
meta
so yeah it's still quite feasible to
train actually
yeah and then of course they have like
the experiment results right so here
they've got it on the visual question
answering with zero shot
stuff so basically they have not
fine-tuned anything it's just after the
pre-training they um yeah validate it
and one thing you can see here is that
when the the model sizes actually get
bigger the performance gets better
which is something that you might expect
yeah then yeah it really is like that
that's what these tables can say and
then they say okay they can outperform
like bigger models
way bigger models actually
um and a lot of these tasks
and they also yeah experiment here I
think that's uh with the fine-tuned it's
a defined one or is that defined one I
think that's a fine tune one
where they yeah
actually fine-tune the query Transformer
and the image encoder so they just leave
the large language model Frozen but for
fine tuning they basically unfreeze the
image encoder and then also yeah take
the image encoders wait and adapt them
for the fine tuning
and again you can see okay bigger is
better and
they are pretty good
in performance else they probably
wouldn't put it in here
um and they're also doing experiments
with captioning right
so they yeah the three main tasks are
doing release visual question answering
like chatting what's in the image and
captioning it's really just like okay
what is an image
and here you can see here they're also
pretty good they've got like best scores
down here
um safely for this no caps set
and for the captioning it's similar to
the visual question answering that they
update the queue form and image encoder
weight and leave the large language
model Frozen
and for the last thing they they
experimented with that's retrieval so
it's image to text or text to image
retrieval that means when you have like
a pool of images
right
um and then you've got a text then you
say okay give me the image that is most
similar to this text that's a text
submission preview and when you have a
pool of texts and one image and you want
to get the text that is most similar to
your image then that's image to text
retrieval
and actually for this tasks they don't
need the large language model so they
just completely leave that out and only
fine tune the image encoder and the
query Transformer
a q former it's not query qformers
that's the right term for it yeah
and as well here right in the
performances
outstanding there's even some 100s in
there they're doing pretty well so all
in all it is a pretty good model and um
yeah
right now it's maybe
maybe the best model that you can use
for
um yeah chatting with image about images
I don't know how far gpd4 image stuff is
right now
but yeah I guess when that comes out it
will be pretty impressive as well
probably better than than blip 2.
um
but especially for open source
things
Flip 2 is pretty nice because you can
also
yeah I mean you can plug in different
image encoders different language large
language models it's quite modular
in the whole setup
um so yeah
I like the paper in general
um maybe my main criticism
like regarding to the paper is that they
could have been
a bit more descriptive about the losses
they're using
so mostly the losses are similar to what
they used in in the first paper and I
think that's why they don't go into
detail on much of that because they're
just like oh yeah it's in the first
paper so we're not talking about it but
they could use a little more detail so
not everyone has to go back to the first
paper and look at what it is about
actually
um yeah
so that's I guess my main criticism
about this whole thing okay
so for this presentation part This Is
the End uh thank you for now
we will
go on and look at how you can actually
use it with a Transformers library from
hugging face just for like five minutes
or so
um but if you have questions about the
paper right now this might be a good
time to ask
nope okay great
then I was either really confusing or
really
good at explaining stuff
so first of all there's a great space
you can use right it's the one by hosts
actually
there's an official passage Force but
the one by Salesforce is not GPU powered
and then you have to wait an eternity so
I recommend this one by husts
um who's actually part of the hugging
phase stuff as well so that will keep on
running
and yeah
here you can basically try out right the
chatting for example or the captioning
you can capture in here
like caption it
and yeah you get a house that looks like
it's upside down and then here over here
you can chat so here you've got like
your
text box you can just
chat with it how could someone get out
of the house a ramp on the side of the
house or it's a slide but
it's okay and then you can go on
shedding right or you can ask isn't it a
slide
wait a second no it is a house true it
is a house
um yeah it's quite funny so it's
I had a lot of funny conversations with
it already
similar to this actually so you always
feel like okay I should have explained
it a bit better
um
it's not that good at getting these
contacts from before like but yeah so
make sure to be really uh
expressive about what you want
here but yeah let's quickly have a look
at how you can actually use that stuff
right in code
so there is um this great notebook by
near here's also one from of the hugging
face stuff and he's got this Transformer
tutorials GitHub repository where he has
just
a bunch of notebooks for all kinds of
yeah models that are in Transformers sud
a lot of them
right now and of course there's also one
for blip 2.
so here UD just go through okay set up
everything
[Music]
um in this version it's even
I think it's yeah
optimized a bit with bits and bytes to
run on into 8 precision
so you load images right blah blah blah
okay that's like the basic image stuff
and then you get to the Transformers
part you can you can use the auto
processor class actually to use the the
weights
um so here he loads the opt 2.7 billion
model
and then you can load the the blip 2
class from Transformers
this one for conditional generation
you can also say from pre-trained again
right so in this model says Force blah
blah blah
oh yeah they need a torch
interior stuff you know
um and then you can start
by passing the image you loaded up there
to the processor which gives you inputs
and then you can generate IDs
um
by loading the model and call generate
with the inputs
and then you get a generated text
processor batch key code right and you
can print the text so that's if you just
want captioning you just have to put in
an image of course right
and if you actually oh yeah it's
prompted image captioning so that's if
you want to use a prompt and then get
get like an image caption again
but sometimes this helps to get a better
image caption actually when you do this
like this is a picture of
and then you can can get better results
than just saying okay here's just the
image but in this case I think it
doesn't matter actually
and yeah it's actually the same process
as above that just that you also have
this prompt which you can put it into
the processor so it's really just this
one
parameter here where we say okay in the
processor we've got a text and that's
the prompt and then you can
just call it again
um yeah generate with the model and then
decoded again with the processor and you
get the text actually
so what if you want to chat with it
right so
yes a visual question answering
again the same but then if you want like
continuous stuff
here you can just actually
concatenate basically the prompts right
so you've got this template question and
answer and then you just get the
question you ask put into the question
one then you get back the answer you put
it into the answer brackets
um and then for the next one
you basically
put that in at the start of the prompt
and
just add the next stuff you want to ask
right so in the end you just put a lot
of these question answer things in a big
array if you want and that's how you can
then prompt it
um yeah to chat with you
basically so I think it's pretty
straightforward that's the nice thing
about Transformers Library you don't
need
many lines of code
and yeah I guess you can have a look
yourself if you want I will also put
these into like the last slide
put some links into into the last slide
when I upload them so then you can check
it out yourself
okay
now that is it
from my side
okay maybe for you at Kensington the
question the the query tokens
um
are they only learned with the
with the cross attention you say
um now well the way they are learned is
right through all these things here
through these losses basically right so
you then adapt them if you get your loss
from image text matching from image text
contrastive learning whatever you get
your your big loss and then you you
adapt them somehow and they get
information from the image encoder
through the cross attention but they
also get information from the text
tokens through the self-attention
uh layer basically
however use
all the same for all images yeah yeah in
a way they are yeah so once you've
learned like when you have learned the
whole stuff these query tokens have
little some values that are set
and then when you do an inference of
course then this
image encoder
again has a cross attention and
yeah it will change the token values
according to like what the image is like
but the initial value is the same for
all images yeah
okay great
well then if there are no more questions
have a great day evening morning
Wherever You Are I don't know
and maybe see you the next time